nancy brophy was in the news this week i
don't know if you know who she is she
wrote the book how to murder your
husband
uh
and then
she
she was uh
convicted of murdering her husband and
we have done this bit before i think it
was when andrew cuomo had a book about
how he was the great governor who solved
all the problems and then he got caught
being a perv
and so it's a little department we call
books that didn't age well
and uh would you like to hear some of
them okay here are some other books that
didn't age well nick cannon's birth
control for dummies did not age one
hunter biden's firewall your complete
guide to laptop security
will smith counting to zen
the secret
to remaining calm under pressure did not
age well
uh matt damon the future is dogecoin
terrible
uh mark zuckerberg how how facebook is
bringing america together did not age
well
uh jennifer lopez's never date your ex
terrible
aging issue there
tom brady's family before football no
[Applause]
johnny depp had taken the plunge when
you know you know
and
madonna had a guide to aging gracefully
that did not really go well
you